hi my name is Dominic to work I'm from
the air TD Austrian Institute of
Technology and my talk will be about
multi physical battery modeling for
predicting the aging behavior of
lithium-ion batteries okay so welcome
everyone to the last session to the last
presentation of this session this
presentation will be about system model
again using the electric energy storages
library for aging prediction of
lithium-ion batteries so I'm like my
colleague dragons image from thee from
the Austrian Institute of Technology's
from the electric drive technologies
business unit so first let me give you a
short overview about this presentation I
will start with some motivation so why
we wear assimilating and why is it
necessary to be able to simulate the
aging behavior of lithium-ion batteries
man I will tell you the approach we're
using the arenas equation followed by
some words about our electric energy
storages library which is a multi
physical library for simulating the
operating behavior of batteries then I
will follow up with simulation with a
description of our simulation models and
finally a scenario div definition and
simulation results and then the outlook
so let us begin with the current
challenges of electric vehicles as you
might know I'm as well like my colleague
from the automotive domain and due to
the increasing environmental awareness
of the ppl electric vehicles become more
and more popular these days the proof of
this we can see that there are a lot of
different electric vehicles on the
market and each big manufacturer has his
own electric vehicles critical factors
for success are currently the costs of
electric vehicles the range of electr
yahiko's charging time and safety and if
there is any problem with any of these
parameters people won't buy electric
vehicles so it's really really hard
issues but we're just at the beginning
of the of the kind of electric era
solution approaches to overcome these
problems are to use lightweight
components to use novel heating or
cooling concepts to increase the range
to optimize the energy efficiency of
electric vehicles and to do so to
increase the range of in electric
vehicles to investigate new battery
technologies to increase the energy or
power density of lithium-ion batteries
or two to optimize the operating
strategy and do some thermal management
in order that the the components don't
get overheat and get get damaged during
operation and as this presentation is
about lithium-ion batteries I want to
say that the last four points which you
can see here apply for for batteries as
well or in special because aging
mechanisms of lithium-ion batteries are
mostly affected by the body battery
temperature and the battery state of
charge and with the with the last four
points bullet points you can really
optimize the state of charge and
temperature you're operating your
battery in so for safety and performance
reasons it is really necessary to
understand aging mechanisms and aging
effects during operation of batteries so
let's have a short look of which aging
effect we were talking about so
basically we're talking about kelland
arrogant cyclic aging effects calendar
Eric aging effects are those effects
which happens regardless of whether you
use your battery or you just store the
battery within the case and and and you
don't draw cord
current out of the battery no matter
which aging effect you're looking at
it's but it's all based on degredation
which is a physical or chemical change
in the active material of the batteries
and this happens due to parasitic
chemical side reactions during operation
the result results which you can observe
when it comes to battery aging are on
the one hand capacity loss so you can
get at the end of life that we've got a
illustration here at the beginning of
the life you have a certain internal
resistance and a certain capacity of the
battery and at the middle of life and
especially at the end of life the the
internal resistance of the batteries
will increase while the capacities that
a the charge you get out of the battery
will decrease so now you might ask who
cares and i will tell you vehicle
manufacturers care because if you
underestimate the battery lifetime no
one will buy an electric vehicle because
if for example BMW claimed that the i3
would have guaranteed lifetime of one
year no one would ever buy a vehicle for
ten thousands of euros while on the
other hand if you overestimate the
battery lifetime no one will ever buy an
electric vehicle again because if BMW
set the i3 had a lifetime of 30 years
and people might be interesting and by
this electrical and standee the vehicle
standstill after eight to ten years they
won't buy an electric vehicle again and
you lose your future so this is why it's
really really necessary to understand
battery aging effect and to be able to
predict the aging behavior so how do we
do it I'm going to show you a very
simple approach which we're using at the
AIT this approaches culty
rias equation the this equation
basically says that the etching rate is
really dependent on the battery
temperature in one hand because the side
reactions or dairy attic recta of the
active material really depends on the
battery temperature the extended
approach also considers the state of
charge as a para as an important
parameter for battery aging and it also
claims that aging effects slow down over
time because you lose over time during a
due to aging effects active material
which you can use so the the energy you
can take out of the battery will get
less and less but this also means that
the energy which is available for the
parasitic side reactions will decrease
as well so the aging effect slow down
over time so we've got here is very
simple equation which tells us tells us
the aging rate of daily of batteries
with regard to the state of charge the
temperature at the time and I've got you
some illustration for scenarios of
different for a different state of
charge and different battery
temperatures and we see here that the
temperature has really a very high
impact on the etching rate we've got
here an aging factor a doubling factor
means that the battery aging mechanisms
take place at double speed and we see
here that the that the temperature has a
very significant impact on the aging
behavior of lithium-ion batteries
because those two graphs are at a state
of charge of 0.5 and a state of charge
of 0.8 at the temperature of 40 degrees
the aging rate is much higher then at
the same state of charge at the lower
temperature so to overcome those
problems and to simulate the aging
behavior of lithium-ion batteries video
a lot a battery library which is called
electric energy storages library we
developed it for extensive applications
so we want to to use our library in very
in a flexible way for different
simulation scenarios and we wanted an
easy configuration of our models so we
really put some some effort in the
parameterization of our models to make
it very intuitive in usage and also to
provide simple usage so just to drag in
the components in your in your basic
model and to have ready to use
drag-and-drop models the main use cases
we developed our library for or on the
one hand electric simulation of
batteries on the one hand it's a thermal
investigation so thermal behavior and
for example to consider cooling circuits
of batteries or to consider the heat up
to determine hot spots during heat up
phases and so on the third use case is
the function development or for example
of battery management system and the
fourth use case is the aging prediction
with these presentations about we see
here a possible application scenario our
battery model in an electric via for we
use the the battery models for an entire
vehicle simulation we had the dip a
turistic below the the vehicle and we
used our electric energy storages
library for electric internal simulation
we built the whole library on a modular
structure as we can see here the basic
concept we've got an electric model
which maps the dynamic material correct
characteristics 10 electric equivalent
circuit we've got also a a thermal model
for simulating the terminal behavior and
parameter adaption model which is kind
of the heart of our of our battery
models because this model calculates the
parameters of of the electric equivalent
circuit with respect to battery aging
with respect to temperature and to to
the state of charge we've got also some
integrated parameter sets for lithium
iron phosphate batteries and nickel
manganese cobalt batteries as I said
before the battery models the electric
models are based on an electric
equivalent circuit we you can simulate
either a static so very simplified
models for a large number of battery
cell so it's a very quick model but you
can also use dynamic models were which
are very accurate in generating results
you can simulate on cell or on stack
level so you can have a serial or
parallel connection of single cells and
you have four in the thermal model
scalable prismatic or cylindrical cell
models so you can scale the battery in
size and you have thermal conduction or
convection heat capacity and so on and
you can build with that determines deck
including cooling system for example to
analyze the impact of different kinds of
cooling systems so air cooling or water
cooling or something like this and we've
got the aging block which considers the
calendar cycle and cyclic aging of the
batteries so we can see here a
screenshot of our of a cell model
implemented in modelica and system
modeler now we've got UD parameter
adaption model which adapts the
parameters and configures the the
electric model which we have here so
it's a very simple model which is very
good for the automotive application it's
very sufficient very fast and it has
sufficient accuracy for you automotive
domain we've got here a an open circuit
voltage
than a serial resistance and up to two
RC circuits to consider also relaxation
and a double layer effect within the
battery we've got here a heat port which
is the interface today to the terminal
model as we see here which is indicated
by this arrow and here we see the
structure of the electric energy
storages library so basically we've got
here the main package is the batteries
package which consists of the cells the
stacks and the components of which the
sales and stacks are composed of so to
enable the user to build his own models
out of our components and we see here
the impedances parameter adaption models
Diagnostics the etching block and
determine models so how did how did we
apply our energy electric energy
storages library we have successfully
applied our library for investigating
the effects that vehicle to grid
scenarios have on the aging effect of
lithium and batteries for those who
don't know vehicle to create scenarios
of vehicle to create strategies are that
if an electric vehicle is connected to
the grid it cannot only be charged by
the electric grid but only support the
the grid during peak power periods for
example in the evening when when people
come home from work they the the
required power from the grid is is
higher and so the electric vehicles
connected to the grid can support the
grid during those periods which means an
additional additional cyclic charge of
the battery so therefore we assumed
battery with an energy content of 25.6
kilowatt hours we we had a look at or
reused driving cycle which we extracted
from daily
rips at given driving distance therefore
we used a frequent driver profiling of
Austria so it's about 60 kilometers long
and for some scenarios which will
explain in a second we considered the
vaquita grids in areas for supporting
the grid as i said at peak power periods
so those are the five scenarios we we
had a look at we simulated the normal
use scenario doesn't use behaviour to
grid and is a kind of reference scenario
so we we drove about 60 kilometers per
day and we charged or battery whenever
we whenever a grid was enabled was
available so either Wendie when the
person was at work or when the person
was at home the second scenario is
controlled charge scenario which as well
doesn't use vehicular grid we have again
a driving test distance per day of 60
kilometers but we charge the battery
only when the grid is ready so if the if
we're in a peak power period of the grid
we won't charge our vehicles the third
scenario is a the first weekly to grin
scenario the kind of normal week of the
grid scenario they are recharged about
six kilowatt hours per day where we
supplied six kilowatt hours to the grid
and recharge those six kilowatt hours
the driving distance we consider in this
example is again 60 kilometers and we
charge when the grid is ready the fourth
scenario is the vehicle to create short
distance scenario which is quite equal
to the normal vehicle recruit scenario
but with a with a decreased driving
distance of only 30 kilometers per day
and the last scenario the fifth scenario
is a weekly to grid scenario with peak
power load where we supplied only half
of the of the energy to the grid but at
a higher rate at a high
power rate so we've got here only three
kilowatt hours per day charged into the
grid and charged back afterwards but
with a required power of six kilowatt
and the rest of the parameters are like
the like the normal vehicle to grid
scenario we used also some environmental
conditions therefore we use detail daily
temperature in Linz in which is in
Austria and we use the average
temperature of the years 1971 to see
2,000 we've got here this temperature
curve in order to be able to to consider
the different temperature aspects during
different times of the year because the
aging effect you must investigate aging
effects una over long periods of time
and so we had to take into account the
ambit bearing temper ambient temperature
as well so here is basically the
implementation of our modelica model and
system modular of the 40-week to create
scenarios we've got here the the thermal
aspects to determine the temperature
profile of lynn's directly connected to
the two cells at the various are very
simplified model only but we could
generate good results with that you see
here the link between the thermal model
and electric model just connected by a
thermal connector we are via a heat port
and we've got here the the electric load
with a current with a constant current
constant voltage charging strategy and
the power load which is either the
vehicle to create scenario or the
driving cycling which we have applied to
the battery and we've got here control
table and some some control strategy
which determines whether the driver is
driving to work or whether the driver is
going home or over the the battery can
be charged
this takes place in the rest of the
model and now let's have a look at the
results with channel are we generated so
first we with we had to to parameterize
our aging model therefore we used some
cell measurements which we which took
place over 105 days we had cycling data
of 1800 full electric cycles and here we
see an example of the how we paralyze
our arenas equation model we've got here
three different measurement measurements
at three different temperatures so at 60
degrees at 45 degrees and at 23 degrees
and we the bullet points are the the
measured results and we fitted a a curve
to get the parameters of the Arrhenius
equation so using these parameters we we
perform the simulation of our five
simulation scenarios and made some
prediction based on this initial initial
measurements we consider the terminal
aspects and the state of charge as well
so what we can see here in the results
is a is the the lifetime or dt predicted
capacity loss during those during the
five applications in areas what we can
see here so okay first of all I want to
mention in the automotive domain you say
that the battery you cannot use the
battery anymore if the Indian even a
capacity was reached which is about
eighty percent of the initial capacity
and if we take this value we see here
that the best-case scenario in the
best-case scenario which which is the
control charge scenario and it's pretty
much the same
is the TV key to encourage a short
distance center area and the normal
Houston area so they are pretty at the
same level we the battery would last for
about six and a half years but if we
would use if you consider the nadas
Daenerys of the worst case in every day
normal vehicle to grid scenario the
battery would only last for let's say
five years so there's a difference of
one and a half year in in the possible
application time of a battery depending
on the operating mode and on the
operating strategy of electric vehicles
and that's why we need those simulation
models and that's why we we're doing
such simulations and for optimizing
operating strategy for considering
terminal aspects for developing new
functions of battery management systems
in order to increase the lifetime of
lithium-ion batteries during operation
so I want to come to the conclusion to
an outlook I showed you some some aging
predicting model prediction model which
we developed and we integrated this
model in our electric energy storages
library the the aging is based on the
arena on an Arrhenius equation
considering temperature state of charge
at the time we considered calendar rig
and cyclic aging the cyclic aging we
considered only with a polynomial
function the capacity loss over the
number of cycles we have some we have
implemented some models which are easy
to parameterize so as I showed you
before the arenas equation is very
simple it doesn't have too much
parameters and you can really achieve
some good simulation results and really
have some good simulations and
predictions about the itching behavior
of lithium-ion batteries and we
you actually performed some aging
prediction based on our initial
measurements which took place 105 days
so in the future we definitely have to
perform some more measurements in order
to validate our predicted behavior the
problem is as we as we've seen before
the aging simulation took place over 10
years in general so it's a very long
time and if we would have batteries
cycles over 10 years in our
infrastructure we couldn't test any
other batteries during that time so it's
very hard to to validate validate the
the predicted aging behavior but one one
approach would be to validate the
predicted aging behavior at higher
temperatures in order to decrease the
battery cycle lifetime so to to have the
the aging effects at a an earlier point
of time and the the last point I want to
mention we want to generate a kind of
generic parameter sets for etching
models for different kinds of cell
chemistry's but therefore we would need
as well more measurements as I said
before so thank you for your attention